Rachel and Dylan here ready to show you  a few tricks to do at home when you  don't want to go outside and crappy  weather to work out  keep burning out the legs try to keep  that back he'll lift it you got fine  your core yeah you have a little longer  way to travel than I did just look on  you good  five four nice how's that feeling three  feeling great easy breezy - yeah one and  done good  so lengthen your legs lift your hips  nice and high keep your hips high bend  and stretch good but still breathe  yeah I gotta breathe on that next one  maybe just bend and hold float a lake  and really just extend the groceries  right out to the side come on down  Center take your arms out to the side  and then lift and lower  look at that wingspan or you can do a  little up down out and down and let's  put the groceries away